jumping right on in
uh i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
uh is there anything that you think
marvel fans might be surprised to learn
about the making of black widow
initially when we were
uh like the first iteration of this
yolena was um
more was written as more of the
traditional
um elena bulova
from the comics uh sort of an
antagonistic character um
adversary uh trying to sort of
you know dethrone natasha and there was
a huge
power dynamic between them it was it was
not nothing like what um
what you see uh but that was the initial
you know thought and uh
let's just say i um it was it was
you know it was a real privilege for me
to be able to executive produce this and
guide
the narrative um away from that
and and and really focus on what the
reality
of of of how women you know interact
which is
really that you know they step up to the
plate to support one another and lift
one another up
um and uh how much more interesting is
that to watch
um you know that kind of dynamic between
two women on screen but they're
somewhere exists another version of what
this could be
which you know i always find fascinating
too to
know how movies start out and then to
see the end result of what they
where they where they go where they what
they become a hundred percent
uh this is a question for both of you um
while kate did a fantastic job
i think there's many people behind the
scenes that actually don't get enough
credit
in bringing these marvel movies to life
and today i wanted to shine a light on
darren prescott who was your second unit
director
and very helpful in terms of you know
the action
uh can you each talk about maybe working
with darren and what goes on behind the
scenes with your second unit director
to craft the insane action in this movie
i don't know if you want to pin
like pick out one particular sequence or
just in general but i would love to hear
from both of you on this
i loved working with jaron he's a solid
dude like
so easy to get along with no fuss no uh
no frills he expects you to come in and
get working and i really like that about
him
we worked on um he's also an an ex-stunt
man
so he gets it he's fully
understanding of what you're trying to
achieve and what you can and can't do
um and we worked on parts of uh the
morocco sequence
uh together and he um
was just i mean so understanding of
the set and the space that we needed and
he really wanted to
get that whole sequence in one and he
knew that i'd been working really hard
on it and
i just i really loved having um
him a understand what goes into it and
be
be prepared to to spend more time on
making sure that that
we got it and that's just so exciting
when someone's like yeah you can do it
let's keep on going until you can do it
let's get let's get it in one
um so i i really really got along with
him he was really cool and then i was on
like three flights with him after the
shoot it was crazy we kept from getting
played and he was like are you stalking
me i was like
no but of course i would etc
yeah darren is fantastic um you know
obviously
shooting second unit you're basically
making an
early you're making a movie it's a it's
all part of a greater whole but it's
like a second whole film
um on the second unit and uh you know
those guys were plugging away the entire
time
uh just filling in pieces of that previz
you know those set those big
set pieces are have been developed for
you know months and months beforehand in
pre-prep
and then you realize okay there's all
these these little pieces we have to
fill in and um
you know sometimes the actual
you know function of shooting something
is
not you know what's laid out in the
previz and
and and you need somebody who has who
can think on their feet
um you know and is a problem solver and
uh and and darren is you know he's uh
you know he's a stunt performer himself
he knows what works
he knows what angles work he knows not
only what you need but most importantly
what you don't need
um you know and i think that's actually
you know that's that's the strength of
somebody who comes from that kind of
background
um they just you know he has incredible
style
and i think you know he and kate really
had such respect for one another because
they both wanted they both wanted they
wanted the action and the drama
and the drama to they wanted the
dramatic
story the emotion of the story to
actually inform
the action set pieces and that's when
you get the most
you know gritty fun to watch stuff
um and then that comes from him from
darren being a performer for sure
thank you so much for your time have a
great day thank you